[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice dr
john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author and host of the ever
popular dr john dolone show on ramsey
networks is my co-host today as we talk
about your relationships your boundaries
your mental health your career your job
and even your money we talk about you
right in front of you right here on the
ramsey show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five we're going to start off to
this hour with uh new york city calling
wait a minute i'm gonna get this right
there it is uh khadidra is with us hey
kadira how are you
hi i'm well thank you for having me sure
what's up in your world
so i have a significant amount of
student loan debt it's around sixty
seven thousand
i also have
around nineteen thousand twenty thousand
in a personal loan repayment as well as
about five thousand in credit card debt
i just received a twenty thousand dollar
bonus from my job and i want to know
what makes the most sense do i apply it
to
the
student loan or do i
pay off the personal loan what makes the
most sense for me that's a good question
thank you for being a listener we
appreciate it and a new listener at that
so um here's what we teach and then the
more important thing is why we teach it
all right we want you to get out of debt
as fast as you possibly can and
apparently you're moving that direction
since you gave me all your debts and
then said i've got some money
um and the reason we want you to get out
of debt as fast as you possibly can is
that frees up your most powerful wealth
building tool which is your income
okay so we're in agreement we want to
get out of that the fastest possible way
we also want to get out of debt in a way
that causes us to actually finish the
plan so
this only works
this suggestion of mine the answer to
your question only works if it's if it's
not the only thing you do but it's part
of the whole thing that you do as you
plug into this whole ramsey ecosystem on
money okay so within that ecosystem
you're going to live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else you're going to sell so much
stuff the kids think they're next you're
going to live on nothing you're not
going out to eat you're not going on a
vacation you're gonna pour every dollar
at this debt with great intensity ah
and then you're gonna get out of debt
okay now if you're gonna do all of that
then this works if you're gonna screw
around with it and ish it
it's not gonna work
so i got to give you that caveat to the
advice now what we in that context what
we teach people to do is list your debts
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything with the smallest debt and
attack the smallest debt and then the
next and then the next and then the next
that gives you a sense of
traction
a sense of power
a sense of destiny that this is going to
work it gives you hope
and so i'm gonna list your five thousand
dollars worth of credit cards and i'm
gonna pay them off and then i'm gonna
pay the rest of it on the personal loan
and as soon as i get that personal loan
gone i don't have any credit card
payments i don't have any personal loans
then i'm going to attack the
student loans with a vengeance because
you're going to pay off all but 5 000 of
the personal loans and you're going to
cut up your stupid credit cards so they
didn't grow back
okay just making sense
yes it's making sense
okay there's a lot of recurring payments
that i need to get rid of on my credit
card so that i can do that yeah well
just move them over your debit card yeah
or in you know that's what i use i use a
debit card and you got to move them over
but chomp them up
get rid of them and if you take 20
thousand and apply it to twenty and five
then that leaves only five thousand on
the personal loan did i do that math
right
yeah okay
and you make how much 90
no i make 160. oh great okay so you're
gonna knock out that other five in like
20 minutes right
yeah yeah and then we're gonna knock out
the student loans in less than one year
and you're going to be free how long
have you had these student loans
since 2015. okay it's time for sally mae
to leave your life
seven years is too long for her to be
invading your space
yes
so john the power of paying off the
smallest to largest that incremental
progress that's exactly psychology about
that john has a phd in psychology so i
can ask him about these things yeah so
do you
you're either overwhelmed or the joy is
welling up inside you and you can't
speak which one is it
i'm a little overwhelmed okay i'm a
little nervous so
just to just to reiterate what dave just
said by the end of today you're gonna
have no credit card debt
you're gonna have five grand left on a
family loan that with your income
hopefully you can go to the bank and get
that five grand and you're out of that
one too
and then after today because of one free
phone call and because you're ready to
knock this thing out then you just gotta
tackle the last big ugly hairy dog there
and move your credit card cut your
credit cards up and get a debit card
right and then you're ready to rock and
roll
that's i there's an intensity to this
though and you feel that is that what's
a little overwhelming
yes i absolutely need to be rid of all
of it yeah so here's what we have
discovered and this is for the benefit
of all our listeners but also for you
what we've discovered is personal
finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
you've been you're a smart lady i can
tell by talking to you just how
articulate you are you've been trying to
fix this with your intellect and it's
not an intellectual problem
it's a i don't get pissed off at sally
may and i'm kicking the old woman out of
my freaking house
problem
there's an emotion a visceral
move to this and that is tied to the
success of people who get out of debt
you cannot fix
a problem that you made emotionally with
an intellectual fix you have to fix it
with an emotional change and that
applies to
marital issues that applies to most
mental health issues you can't think
your way out of most of these problems
you can get a plan cognitively but then
you got to go do you got to go be
different you got to act different right
little by little by little yeah good
that's a great call and that's for you
know her call is for all of you
out there so
here's the deal they actually did a
study at northwestern university
that uh studied the idea of paying off
your debts highest interest rate first
versus smallest to largest
and the conclusion of this university
study was
dave ramsey's right
and we're like well we kind of already
knew that because we already taught 10
million people how to do this while you
guys were doing this study up there in a
vacuum but um dave i've been at those
tables where we're discussing data and
everyone
kind of hangs their head like oh man we
didn't expect these findings i just
imagined that table they were going to
show you no i i well i don't know i
don't know whether they should
if they if they they did at least come
out and publicly
they put it out okay and they literally
did say all this time ramsey's been
right yeah you know so i don't know
whether they were trying to prove me
right or prove me wrong but it doesn't
matter we already knew we were right
because we had more proof social text
than proof texts than they had so we
already knew that we had more data than
they would have ever seen with a number
of people that have actually done this
but that's the thing guys you've got to
have a level of hope and you know your
behaviors your impulse your lack of
control your disorganization your
immaturity your inability to delay
pleasure these are all things that you
got to fix it's called growing up
and when you do and you apply a that a
behavior fix
to getting out of debt you'll get out of
debt but when you try to intellect your
way out of a behavior problem you can't
do it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two
john's brand new book is called own your
past change your future it is on
pre-sale right now for only twenty
dollars and john's got two phds 20 years
of counseling experience packed it into
an easy to understand book this book is
going to have a positive impact on
everyone everyone should read this book
i got to tell you i personally
it's changed some of the language i'm
using not only with you guys but inside
my own head as well and that's just from
me reading through the manuscript
because it's got my name on the
publishing and so i want to know what
the flip we were saying before we put it
out there and it turns out you know
it'll help like a 30 year old that's
looking to sharpen their mind this is
not a thing you have to like this is a
book for crazy people it's not it's a
book for all of us have a little crazy
and we all could adjust it a little bit
that's right all of us have some things
we could polish up and just
you know a little more peace a little
less anxiety all of us could adjust the
way we're looking at certain things and
you give a framework for doing that and
that's why i think this book's going to
blow up yeah there's a lot of books out
there that are scholars talking to
scholars and they're fine and they're
good and they're important and there's a
lot of books out there on
what i call way outside the bell curve
for some significant mental illness for
folks who are practitioners there's
almost nothing for folks who are just
trying to live life better right have a
better conversation that's right with
yourself that's right have a better
conversation with uh your friend i mean
the people you love right you know in
our world today we were talking about
this before we went on the air um
you know the number of times that two
people can just sit down and
almost enjoy a good argument just
because we can have a good discussion
because we still love each other we did
before we started and after we finished
the argument we still think you're wrong
but i still love you of course and but
everybody you have to hate everybody and
you have to chop off everything
in our divisive world out there it's
like well you think you you you you you
have a mask or you don't have a mask and
so i'm pissed at you for the rest of
your life you know what i mean it's like
people are losing their dadgum minds out
well they're gone man and so you know
we need some new tools
to control ourselves and also to
interface with other people and just to
walk it back you know what i mean we've
laughed internally and not laughed but
we've thought really we look at the
number of conversation cards we've sold
like is that where we are and the
reality is yep that's where we are that
we we're starting over kind of like old
school you gotta get a thousand bucks
and let's just start there right that's
where we are when it comes to
relationships and our mental health
right now and let's do it and let's just
stop pretending let's stop walking
around the problem let's go right
through the middle of it well and and to
my knowledge none of our leadership team
or publishing team has significant
mental health
problems right to my knowledge and every
one of them were touched
including me and informed and given new
tools by reading this book own your past
change your future you know we've taught
god's and grandma's ways of handling
money for 30 years here at ramsey and
john's doing the same thing now god's
and grandma's ways of doing
relationships doing mental health it is
a complex topic but
people that are smart can take a complex
topic and make it simple around here we
call it putting the cookies on a shelf
where everyone can reach them so
pre-order your copy today at
ramseysolutions.com it's 20 bucks you're
going to get the audio version of the
book the ebook version of the book and
you're going to get one month of free
weekly therapy sessions from the fine
folks that better help who have come
alongside that makes this 20 purchase an
unbelievable deal so ramsey
solutions.com and check it out the new
book coming out in april get it
pre-ordered now to get all the goodies
on your past
change your future our question of the
day comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping with the two new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from david in oregon david writes
i've been paying the bills but not doing
a proper budget since my wife and i got
married i thought i could do it and we
coasted up by for about 10 years then
kids came time flew by and we
accumulated 30 thousand dollars in debt
i never made my spouse part of the
process and held her off so she didn't
have to feel the financial burden
she has a quote unquote feeling that
something isn't right when i won't let
her see our finances and she's right i
recently read one of dave's tweets look
at you using twitter to help people i
didn't know that was possible it said if
you're in a committed relationship
you've got to play with all of your
cards face up how do we start over and
do it right this time
this is a moment this is it one of those
cool mirrors a really great question i
love this question
so dave in my life
when i've i've had several of these in
my marriage over 20 years
it always starts with me saying
we need to have a discussion
and i need to i need to
invite you into some hard stuff that's
going on in my heart mind my actions
whatever and i start with i'm sorry i've
been living this way and i haven't
brought you along i've left you out i've
excluded you whatever the thing is
and
i want to invite you in to help make
this right and she's very right to feel
betrayed she's very right or her
feelings are gonna be her feelings but
it starts with somebody
turning the lights on turn the music off
and saying i was wrong and i'm sorry
let's start here
yeah and i gotta tell you that i've
walked couples through this
and sometimes i played marriage
counselor for five minutes in the middle
of a coaching session on money
uh in this
and if he will just i got 99 percent of
the time if if dude you got the perfect
heart she's got the right heart actually
both of you do for this for this to be
successful and so
i would just say look i have screwed
this up i'm sorry
the reason i screwed it up was it
started off with i was just going to
take care of it i was going to man up so
you didn't have to worry about it
and then it got out of control and i was
ashamed
that i didn't
do it right
and that caused me to even become
more guarded of it and i should have
just brought the whole thing to you and
we should have worked on it together and
i really screwed up but i screwed up
because i was trying to
be the man and carry this for you and
that's not the right way to be a man by
the way
and i was trying and then when it fell
apart and i couldn't do it then i was
ashamed of myself and i didn't want to
didn't want to reveal to you that i had
screwed up because i felt i felt stupid
and so if he just says that which is
what he said right but if he just says
that to her she's going to be really
forgiving oh man and
this usually when i see a couple like
this there's something underneath it
which
there's something about the way they
communicate in this home that she
doesn't like so if this is
my wife
she will
not say hey i've got a feeling she will
insert herself into this process right
so there's something about it could be
that they've been married five years and
you've been married twenty that that's
well even ten years first five years
sharon would have been this now sharon
would be like what
it's going
very similar here it's different now
yeah after 40 years you know we we kind
of cut through the bull you know so
those one-hour conversations are six six
seconds yeah it's like
not i have a feeling it's like ah you're
scheming and scamming what the crap's
going on
but something here is going to have to
change in how they do because this is
going to show up money's going to show
up with kids it's going to show up
let's let's come up with a new way of
doing business of loving each other and
and here here's the lesson that you get
out of this and you learn it through the
money lens and it will affect your whole
marriage to your point and the lesson
that you get out of it is so beautiful
is this that everything you do is going
to be better when you do it together
right
instead of you trying to give her the
gift of her not having to worry right
that is not a real gift and everything
that's a falsehood have a feeling uh hey
something's not right
develop a language that y'all can ask
each other that question yeah it just
does away with it right right away just
goes away it's poof
you deal with it you move on oh and by
the way this also tells us that your
wife has really really good intuition
yep and so the next time she has a
feeling
about the car salesman but you think you
want to buy the truck anyway you need to
get off the lot yep because her feelings
are probably pretty intuitive probably
pretty accurate it might be god speaking
through her i've learned that the hard
way yeah i
if sharon said sharon's southern so she
says she it's a seven syllable word i
got a bad feeling and if she gets a bad
feeling and i go against it cost me 10
grand at least
i just quit doing it i just don't go
against those feelings they're expensive
i'm i've been wrong almost every single
time i just i mean we have to get on the
same page and i i don't violate that i
mean i'll question her i'm like was it
last night's pizza i mean why are you
having a feeling but but she's like no
no this guy i just think he's a bad guy
i don't know what it is but i can't put
my finger on it but i got a bad feeling
oh geez we're getting away from that guy
oh he's playing asap gonna find out
later what happened with him
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage stephen
and melissa are with us hey guys how are
you doing well pretty good dave how are
you good to have you guys where do you
all live eaton ohio eaton ohio where is
eaton uh just outside dayton oh okay i
can do that i know where dayton is all
right good good to have you guys welcome
to nashville how much debt have you paid
off 55 000 all right way to go how long
did this take
uh seven months
that's quick
and your range of income during that
time 140 000. cool what do y'all do for
a living i'm a cnc machinist and i'm a
financial analyst cool what's a cnc
machine i know cnc music factory i don't
know cnc machinist what's that uh it's
basically instead of a manual machining
uh basically computer programs and we're
cutting up parts company i work for
actually cuts uh silicon parts that go
in the process of making computer chips
oh wow that's good
make more make more we're trying very
busy year all right so yeah really
catch up catch up all right cool man
very cool what kind of debt was the 55
000 it was our mortgage
whoa
did a tiny little mortgage yeah yeah we
had a large down payment
a large down payment and what's this
house worth about 175 yeah
how old are you two i'm 31 and i'm 29
and you have a paid for house y'all are
so weird
wow
weird people
it's the least weirdest thing about us i
like it
way to go you guys how fun
so what in the world who sets up
themselves to put that kind of down
payment and be a hundred percent
debt-free house and everything by the
time you're freaking 30 years old where
does all of this come from how do you
learn this where's your story of ramsey
what in the world
uh well i've listened to you for about
10 years now and i never had any
consumer debt
i'd gone to a couple of your live events
and when me and steven started dating a
few years ago i was trying to get him to
come aboard which he did he paid off his
car and
agreed we would never get another car
loan and all kinds of things like that
so we were pretty much wanting to pay
cash for a house
um and i'll let you finish well uh she
was working multiple jobs i was working
my job plus we both were doing ins cart
and pretty much all our free time that
we were allowed to
and
you know we were going to cash flow it
and we were surprised a little early
about our daughter arriving you know
sooner than expected so we decided if we
found a house beforehand that we you
know fell in love with we'd go ahead and
get a small mortgage with the gold
painted off within a year which you know
seven months later
so how old is your little baby 10 months
oh so you move in three months before
yeah
you bought the house three months before
the baby came yeah well you're brave
and you're brave moving a pregnant woman
into a new house dude
you called my show i would have said
hold off man well done wow and we found
a house that we loved so yeah it worked
out perfectly yeah and you had a plan to
go ahead and knock it out yeah and
that's pretty cool yep so i mean so you
say you grew up listening and then you
converted him when y'all got married
yeah so uh who were your biggest
cheerleaders people outside of y'all
looking at like you like you've lost
your minds uh we're pretty private
people so not too many people know about
it honestly um but we definitely try to
like preach debt-free living to anybody
who will listen and our families um i'm
sure are proud of us so
[Laughter]
we think they are
so i'm just imagining at the machine
shop you make a good living you work
hard there's some dudes with some big
trucks and some jacked up jeeps and the
one guy with every parking lot's got the
guy with a tesla now and then you're
rolling in with your old and you're just
dumping all your money into the house
yeah what are you doing people uh for
taurus yeah that's here you're the guy
with the taurus right i used to have it
with the paid for house
yeah so
how do you deal with the guys just
giving it to you all the time
just stay focused i mean we're on our
own little journey you know it's not
about what they have or
what we can have you know what that's
what we can afford what we can live with
so i know you make silicone chips if you
can bottle what you just said and sell
it you will be a trillionaire okay good
for you man
it's like none of their business i don't
care it's just me and her i'm just i'm
getting out of debt and there's whatever
they want to do is okay it's just
one of the keys to becoming wealthy is
you quit caring what other people think
i'm just saying one of the keys to
winning earth is what you just said good
for
wow
way to go you guys absolutely incredible
so what is the key to staying you guys
are like preventative medicine mainly
you almost are completely stayed out of
that
and and getting out of that what are the
what's the big key
uh definitely staying focused on your
you know your joint goal um i wouldn't
we wouldn't have been able to do it if
the other person wasn't on board
definitely making sure that you're in
alignment with each other and you have
the same goals and the same passion to
live you know your life later on um you
know without debt and again like he said
with contentment with what we have
so you had rent before yeah
and now you have no payments in the
world exactly have you got that one
check yet when you don't owe anybody
anything and you just stare at your own
money yes yeah we paid it off in
september so we've been living that way
a little while how does that feel yeah
it feels great it's nice
it's been great to go on vacation and
not really worry you know we have a
budget of course but um not really being
concerned you can kind of do anything
you want to do yeah i mean life is
pretty good how did y'all grow up with
money
i was terrible with money i you know
i've worked this job for over 12 years
but it was just
paycheck to paycheck spend all i can
take a lot of vacations or
you know go to casino whatever yeah
yeah i i grew up with um i forget the
way rachel freezes it but money was not
a
hot topic it wasn't a good a good thing
to really bring up so
that's probably why i'm so
you know i want to make sure that we're
secure and our future children and our
our daughter is safe
if it was brought up it was explosive
exactly yeah okay so when you when you
think about your childhood and then you
look at that beautiful little girl
what's it feel like to know
we have just done a 180 on her on her
trajectory it feels great i i keep
trying to tell him like we could pay for
her first house you know when she gets
married or at least help out a lot with
it so that maybe they don't ever have a
mortgage and our grandchildren may not
have a mortgage i had a friend of mine
did that he made the kids sign a letter
promising they would never borrow a dime
and he'd give him a house yeah and he
said they're millionaires by the time
they were 20 right i mean 25 right not
20 but 25 and it's just pretty
incredible yeah wow you guys are cool
i love it we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you number one best
seller that is the next chapter in your
story for sure if you're not there yet
you'll be there soon and uh of course a
copy of the total money makeover for you
to give away and disrupt someone cause a
holy ruckus with that you probably got
somebody in mind needs to read that that
ought to go do what you guys have done
all right well let's get the uh young
lady into the picture and what's her
name and how old is she uh raelynn and
she is 10 months 10 months oh look oh
and janelle didn't want to hand her over
janelle just keep holding her
that was bouncing her on her knee that
was so cute so cute well done stephen
and melissa and raelynn dayton ohio 55
000 paid off in seven months oh by the
way that was their house they're a
hundred percent debt free at 29 and 31
years old making 140 a year count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one we're debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it
oh baby that is awesome
man their future is bright i remember
i mean i just remember when josephine
was that little
oh my goodness watching them hold their
baby yeah
it goes so fast and you guys have just
changed her
existence and she doesn't even know
the level of stress that's not in their
house
and will never be in their house because
the number one thing people fight about
the number one stress point in marriage
the number one cause of divorce money
fights money problems money stresses and
that daughter is gonna never feel it
that daughter when she goes to
elementary school in middle school high
school she's got two parents who are
like we don't care that people think
this is who we are and she's gonna be
firmly rooted in all aspects of her
identity man
that's unbelievable oh you're setting up
but you're setting up a whole winning
thing here that is way beyond just
paying off the house well done well done
well done wow they're heroes man rock
stars i'm so proud of them
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host alexander is in charleston south
carolina hi alexander how are
you i'm doing well dave i gotta say it's
an honor to speak to the both of you you
too sir how can we help
uh i just had a quick question because
uh my wife and i started doing the baby
steps over again i got out of debt
before we got married i paid for her
ring in cash and then we got married and
brought her student loan debt in
so we're starting from square one and
you say at the with the baby step two
you should stop all investments does
that mean i should turn my uh my
employees savings account that they use
for my 401k should i just turn that off
for now until i'm done yes sir
okay
now here's why
okay
it's not really
that much difference in the math
but there's something that happens in
your brain when you go whole hog when
you completely focus on a single goal to
the detriment of all other goals
when you completely sell out
for getting out of debt it increases not
only the probability that you're going
to get out of that but the speed at
which you do it and it does free up a
little bit of money the money that was
going into the 401k temporarily is not
going there temporarily it is going to
your debts but more than anything it's
you going
i'm in i'm doing this and there's
something about that level of
uh focus that level of commitment that
breaks things loose in your life because
you start you go you look over there and
you go well we can't really buy that
thing because that's going to mean one
more month that i'm in debt and one more
month i'm not in the 401k and that
pissing me off because i want to be in
my 401k so
it just keeps dialing it back down and
focusing it back down to where you're
putting blinders on your financial life
and on your the psychology of the
situation to be able to focus
exclusively on one thing john what is
the power that comes from that that i'm
describing
i'm just listening i'm thinking of
this is just pure unadulterated rage
right so alexander just thinking about
pausing does that does that make your
heart rate go up
it does and it doesn't because like i
said i've been you know gazelle the day
before and i got the wife to join the
cause but you know it's it's different
now for me because you know i'm married
now i got a family that i'm gonna take
care of we're thinking about expanding
our family in a couple of years and you
know so we want to be free right and so
let this like it does and it doesn't it
does right and you're a cool cucumber
like no it's cool
it does and it should right it's a good
kind of anger that's right it's a it
drives action yeah it's a righteous rage
man like i'm not gonna ever find myself
in this situation ever again we're not
going to i love how you're changing your
pronouns we're not going to right we're
going to keep going and going and going
mary's in louisville kentucky hi mary
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call
um
my question is um in 2014 i went through
a nasty divorce
and uh 2015 i rented for a year and then
i bought a condo
uh in a couple weeks i'm getting ready
to sell my condo and last year i remarry
so uh the house that my husband was
living in
together we
moved in obviously we got married
between 2021
uh he owes we owe like 68 000 on the
house
and
um
when i sell this condo i'm going to get
about
90 000 from the sale of the condo
so i don't know whether to just go ahead
and say let's pay off the house
or should i invest it in our retirement
well with the exception of the fact that
you've been through a lot of pain
and um
so you're probably a little gun shy
uh but if you if let's just say let's
dial this back and say okay you call me
up you're 25 years old and you're brand
new married and you've never been
married before and never had the scars
of of the hurt and the pain in the
broken heart of a divorce
and uh all of that and you call me up
the question's a no-brainer we pay down
the house
right okay so that's the answer of the
right way to do this financially but if
i'm in your shoes that might be hard for
me to do and i might want some checks
and balances in place
uh because um
you know i've just got these scars and
so the checks and balances would be that
your name is on the deed on the new
house and that there's a will
that both of you sign that in the event
of his death the house is yours in the
event of your death the house is his
and uh we're not there you know former
kids from former marriages or whatever
are not getting his kids aren't getting
at your 90 grand that you paid down on
his house and you know we got to have a
lot of clarity and legal documents on
all of that and if he's unwilling to do
that then that's going to spook me
yeah and
in something else i've got a 403 b and
i've got an ra
and i have one son he has three kids
and before we got married he brought up
he said uh before we get married i just
want you to know that
something happens to you
uh
your money is going to go to your son he
doesn't have to even think about
splitting it with my three that's just a
given well then you need to change the
beneficiary on your 401k or your 403b
to name your son
yes i did okay i did all right then
that's already taken care of and that's
fine so he so your husband your new
husband
gets it
yes but we need to discuss then what's
going to happen with the house we've
already discussed what's going to happen
the retirement it's going to the kids
okay but what's going to happen with the
house that we own together and it was
yours before but now i'm putting 90
grand into it have you all had that
conversation already
uh we've kind of
jumped around it haven't really come
right out and said okay we're going to
do this yeah you need to you need to
know that your 90 grand is protected and
that you own the house when he dies or
you don't put the money in the house and
i i care less about the the dollar
amount and i care more about that you're
not homeless if he passes away right
or that his kids don't come out and say
hey that house is ours we're going to
sell it
and we'll give you your 60 grand back
but you're homeless yeah it's it's just
good clarity and you know it it could be
the one thing that you guys decide okay
this is something we are doing together
to the exclusion of our children his
retirement goes to his kids your
retirement goes to your kids but
this this piece of the wealth we're
going to is our new life and we're going
to do this house together and basically
basically you're buying into
this house and this gives you a vision
for the future it's something you can
share on that if you don't do that
i kind of think you got a problem yeah
you might want to sell that house and
the two of you do go buy a house that
you can own together and go into the
future
uh if he's stuck on his house kind of
thing i don't think he is though
scott sounds like he's pretty
open-handed i i like him already so it's
good stuff bill is in mobile hi bill
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can i help
i have a question a tax question uh
relating to a car that i sold last
summer um i bought it three years ago
um pre-owned and i think it's a limited
edition sports car i think it's
considered a collectible
um i paid
about
40 000 above msrp when i bought it and
then i ended up selling it
for about 18 000 less than i bought it
for so i'm wondering
um can i write that 18 000 off um
against other capital gains no that's a
loss off that no
because you drove the car it's not a
collectible you drove the car
it's your daily dude it's your daily
driver right
yes sir yeah you just bought a car and
lost money on cars all you did and you
can't what kind of if it's if it's a
business
you could do that if you had if you're
in the business of collecting cars and
that would mean the car was like sitting
in the garage it wasn't a daily driver
and you're in it's an investment and
you're buying the car as an investment
and you do you regularly trade cars as a
part of your ongoing club car
collectible business collectible car
business yeah you could write off a loss
then but i don't think you can you could
double check with a tax advisor to be
sure i'm not very good at taxes so i
could be wrong but i don't think you can
so i'm with john what kind of car what
is this
it was a course 911 gt3 rs oh my god so
what have we learned here what what wait
a minute what color was it
it was black with uh green
accents
that's awesome is a beast of an
automobile dude the the studio is
getting warm for those of you listen i
can't i can't believe you that that
thing didn't bring more than that
in this weird market
it's currently bringing about 250 yeah
so you just got burned on the up sale
yes sir i i i if i would have sold it
private sale um i think i could have
sold a price for more than i bought it
for but um
oh
there it is okay so you could have got
out of it but you flip flipped it into
the next deal
wow
well i don't think you can double check
your tax cut to be sure but i'm pretty
sure
that i'm right i've been wrong before
though this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
baloney ramsey personality best-selling
author host of the dr john dolone's show
is my co-host today we'll be taking your
questions about your relationships
mental health your anxiety your
boundaries your family your job your
career your money your wealth whatever
it is you want to talk about basically
we're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in the call is free some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it
gene is with us in cincinnati hi gene
welcome to the ramsey show
hi i'm so excited to talk to you you too
what's up
so my husband and i um need your advice
um
about
a subject that we're conflicted on so
we have been going to a church um
for about a year we both had our own
churches we got married several years
ago and and it took us a while to find
our church and we're very comfortable
with this church
um
but um we're conflicted on whether we
should
help with something over and above our
tithe and we're conflicted on that so
i'm calling to see if you can help us
wade through this so why are you
conflicted um
well
our pastor
um
he addressed the church recently to
explain this church is about 10 years
old or so 10 12 years old
and he explained that
when they
started this church they started
storefront and then they found this
property and they borrowed
money to
purchase this property and to do
renovations
and
so he said it was
350 to 400 000
total
and um he came before the church
recently to say that they owe maybe 250
000 or so on the church
and
um he would like us as a church
as as we can
his goal is to try to get this debt paid
off
but he also indicated he would like to
expand the church
and build a bigger sanctuary etc without
explaining whether or not they're going
to borrow to do that
and i
am dave ramsey fight and so my husband
and i are debt-free and we're totally
in 100 agreement on that and um we also
tied
and i want to help but i don't want to
help them pay this debt off
to help them go get another loan
and there's not a lot of transparency in
this church we've been there for a year
we don't know what tithes are there's
our former churches both of our former
churches i came from a very large church
he came from a very
small church
or very transparent about contributions
tithing and then where that money was
going and we both came from debt-free
churches does the church um
if you went in and met with a pastor uh
and asked for the annual budget would
they give it to you
well that's what i said to my husband i
i that's how i think we need to approach
that he he feels like it's
he's uncomfortable
it's almost like he feels like he's
questioning our pastor no and i and i
said no i i think we have a right to
know where this money's going and then
i'm uh what we call around ramsey i'm
invested in this i'm a stakeholder
okay and so yeah you know you're you're
a stakeholder you're you're you're a
stockholder in a sense you're a tither
and so it's not um you're not
questioning someone's character and you
can make that plain you just go listen
we just want to know we've been tithing
and it brought up the discussion and we
just want to make sure you know we're
real diligent with our finances it
appears you guys are
and love to see a copy of the budget
um
i will not tithe and attend a place that
will not allow the tither to see the
budget
because that i i've just been around i
mean 50 000 churches have taught
financial peace university so believe me
we've seen some stinkers
okay and i don't you know there's only
one reason to hide something
or to not disclose something something's
wrong
that's the only reason there's i think i
think they're gonna i think they're
going to let you see the budget i don't
think they're going to be a problem with
it it's very standard but they just
don't make it as a big deal about
publishing it everywhere maybe they
don't want in the paper or whatever i
don't blame them uh but but if you went
in and sat down had lunch and say hey i
need to ask you a couple questions we
want to give to this new project and we
want to continue to be tithers we've
made this our home church we love you we
trust you uh as a matter of just our
normal course of business we'd like to
look at the budget and i want to ask you
about your plans to continue to borrow
because i'm an anti-debt freak
and i just i just want to know about
that and we're not going to leave the
church over it we're not going to be mad
at you we're not going to cause
divisiveness we're not going to gossip
we're not going to work against you we
just want to know what's going on and so
how and and so we can feel comfortable
supporting the whole process and to hear
what dave just said there which is
masterful which is this is our
our philosophies is our problem
not yours we're not coming at him guns
are blazing but this is how we do life
and we want to see if if this is
something we want to partner with
and they want to be a good steward yeah
okay well you don't have to say that
because it indicates to him that he's a
bad steward if he doesn't do it your way
is there something else that you're not
finding trustworthy there it feels like
there's something beneath this it's not
that we we love this pastor and we
believe that he is um the real deal he
is amazing cool
how big a church is
it's it's um
maybe three four hundred people it's a
smaller church than i'm used to okay
well he's the things he's doing now are
going to lay the foundation for you to
go to 3 000 or they're going to keep you
at 300.
that's what he wants he wants to grow
this i know but he's not going to grow
it if he doesn't make the decisions you
and i are talking about properly
right because it is part of the process
you have to lay a foundation literally
uh in order to start building until you
know exactly we've talked about that you
talk about that the bible talks about it
and well
that's all numbers the numbers on
churches let me tell you it's it's like
90 of the pastors are gone within five
years of a multi-million dollar building
project
they don't make it
it ends up costing them their job
90 or they leverage it to go to a bigger
church well something but it's just
they're they're not there they don't see
it through
and so i was at a church the other day
that that uh i'm friends with and i'm
friends with the pastor i'm friends with
the last five pastors they've had that's
how old i am and so and this guy is
still saddled with the debt of a guy
four pastors ago
from a project and he's he's swimming in
it man and it's a mess so i don't
believe in it i'm with you but i'm also
i'm also don't tell people to leave a
church just because of debt i don't and
i don't know i don't want to leave this
church i'm not and i'm not i don't want
to i don't want to pay off debt so he
can go borrow more money and i don't
blame you i don't blame you i wouldn't i
i could i could keep tithing there
if i were you and keep attending there
if i could see the budget
and not participate in the debt
reduction or building program because
it's going to be end up with more debt
if he says no we're going to borrow
i could do that with good conscience i'd
be fine
but i'm not i'm with you i can't give to
something where the bank is going to be
the beneficiary of it not god's kingdom
and god's kingdom has absolutely nothing
to do with banks i am sure of that
shots fired
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
people are craving connection they're
craving community they're craving the
energy that only comes from humans
being
with
other humans and we know that we hear
you we need it too
uh we gotta get back out there people we
gotta get back to your cities we've been
coming to your cities for 20 30 years
and we miss it and we're about to get
back at it so first up we're going to do
building wealth live we're doing the
tour
we're announcing and have almost sold
out already orlando on may the 19th
that's george campbell rachel cruz and i
oh and we're going to bring dr john
dolone and king coleman for some side
sessions as well while we're there and
then we're going to announce five more
cities one more this spring and four
more in the fall for the building wealth
live and we're bringing back to dallas
october 22 the smart conference
yeah you're gonna be smarter it's a
day-long event you will leave exhausted
and inspired and better and smarter in
every area of your life from mental
health to money to career to anything
you want to talk about we're going to
cover it that day uh amy and craig
groschel our friends from lifechurch.tv
over in oklahoma city the largest church
in america are going to do the marriage
section for us i'm really looking
forward to having them with us the smart
conference october 22nd in dallas so far
the first building wealth live not quite
sold out orlando may 19th you can still
get tickets but you do need to get them
ramsey solutions dot com slash events
ramsey solutions dot com slash events it
is time to get back out in the real
world with people john
i can't wait
so time to talk about uh james our
producer has come up with this great
idea that every so often we should
feature some greedy rich people
because we all know that rich people are
horrible
we all know that it's a horrible thing
that they're going to hell because the
camel can't get through the eye of a
needle we know
that rich people are awful that that the
love of money is the root of all evil
well they just they're they're dragging
america into the into the sewer we're
just dragging america greedy rich people
drag america into prosperity against its
will
and it's just awful it should stop
they're greedy they're awful we featured
several of them lately uh shaq and some
money that he gave away that were
ridiculous and worse dolly pardon it was
awful how much money she's given away
she's just ruining the reputation of the
greedy rich people and kids to read
this guy i got to know this guy
personally before he died and i hate to
talk bad about people that died but he's
rich terry stewart deserves to be talked
about because he's a greedy rich guy so
here's what happened
in 1971 larry was homeless before he was
a gritty rich guy
and he was broke
no money and hungry
so he went into a diner in houston
mississippi this is known as a small
town
[Applause]
sat at the counter ordered a sandwich
got a sandwich finished eating the owner
of the diner was observing this guy
realized he had absolutely no money
walked around behind him and reached
under the stool that the guy was sitting
on and said hey mister i think you
dropped this and handed him a 20 bill
wow
to pay for his lunch
and larry said if i ever get any money
i'm going to do that a lot
well larry went on to move to kansas
city got in the cable business became a
multi-millionaire and started a thing
for many years no one knew who it was he
was called secret santa
and he would dress up as santa claus
with a police escort and give away tens
of thousands of dollars a hundred 200 at
a time just walking down the street
seeing someone making eye contact with
them and going that person needs a lift
that person needs a smile that person
needs a couple hundred bucks and so he
went to uh new orleans during after
katrina he went to new york city after
um after 9-1-1 before that many to other
cities he was just find a place where
they were having a hard time
there had been some kind of a disaster
catastrophe tragedy and he would go in
to cheer everyone up as secret santa
it started in kansas city his hometown
the kansas city star followed him around
for years the newspaper trying to figure
out who he was never could find out
whose secret santa was it was a big deal
we knew about it we talked about it on
this show years and years ago and then
uh sadly larry got cancer
and i was given a death sentence
and uh and he came on the show
and we had featured him several times
but we didn't know who he was and uh
then he came on the show and revealed
on this show who he was
told america who he was and um
then he asked everyone to co-become
secret santas and he actually set up a
kit to show you how to do it and that
was his legacy that he wanted to leave
before he passed away it's estimated
that larry stewart this greedy rich guy
gave away well over a million dollars
millions of dollars
as secret santa over the years but now
has inspired a whole nother generation
of secret santas and we don't know who
they are but they're also of course
greedy rich people man
rich people should be ashamed of
yourselves
and i'm probably not supposed to say
this but i've been on the road with you
before
and
i've seen you i've seen people's eyes
bug out just because you're so generous
with folks who are helping with bags and
things like that
which has inspired me it's there's
something about
hey i don't have a million dollars to
give or i can't give ten thousand
dollars this project there's something
life-giving about saying i can make this
person i'm just gonna grab this gas
especially these days i'm gonna grab the
gas i'm just gonna go stick my debit
card in this person's gas is they're
getting out of the car this mother
getting out of the car
and i'm not gonna say anything other
than blessings to you i hope you have a
hope your day's a little bit better
handing somebody a hundred bucks as a
tip instead of the expected two dollars
there's something about being able to do
that and seeing an entire it just they
they turn into sunshine right it's just
this because it restores it's not just
about the money it's about humanity it's
about i thought everyone's against me
and this person's not and it's something
magical man and it's infectious yeah but
the ugly rich people should stop doing
that yes yes yes yes middle class and
under middle class folks you're giving a
bad reputation to the greedy rich people
when you do this stuff i know you're
supposed to you're unbelievably generous
and you just blow people's minds it just
messes up the whole
the whole narrative that greedy rich
people should all be punished and give
their fair share i mean you're messing
up the narrative when you're from
private jets to your special parties
that you i don't know what i'm trying to
make something up now yeah but all right
hats off to our friend who's uh
graduated onto heaven larry stewart
the original
secret santa
and uh
there's currently secret santa's
literally all over this is so cool all
because of him that's a great legacy
well done larry well done my friend i
can't think of i mean
that's a pretty incredible legacy
you talk about fun that's fun it's such
a oh it's so fun it's unfair how fun
that is
[Laughter]
rose is in sacramento
rose welcome to the ramsay show
rose hi thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
hi so um i actually have a question i
have two little girls and one is
just about the age where she's starting
to understand the concept of money and
learning that she can um you know make
money and buy stuff for herself that we
generally don't buy for her
is she 22 how old is she
[Music]
she's five okay
that's fine she's five and how's your
little girl
she's 18 months okay and your question
um so my question is i did not grow up
with a great financial advice and
thankfully my husband and i found you
when we were in our 20s and now we would
like to
kind of set our daughters up so we want
to know um do we
do you suggest us giving an allowance um
an age-appropriate allowance with the
purpose of learning to save spend um and
give
would they be attached to chores um
because we want her to know that she has
to participate in the house like making
her bed and cleaning up her toys and we
don't really want those to be
incentive-based i agree so here's
here's what we do with a five-year-old
yeah here's what we did number one it's
age-appropriate so take it easy she's
just five
okay we're not sending them the salt
mines but she has a princess dress
our goal is to do four things with money
we want to teach kids to work
age appropriately let's make up your bed
when you're four pick up your toys when
you're five okay
uh and i'll help you but you get all the
credit emotionally for doing it um
we but and then we pay you and so
there's a connection between work and
money so you're on commission you're not
on allowance words are powerful
allowance sounds like welfare
we don't we need to make allowance for
you you're awesome
you can bring it so bring it rockstar
toy cleaner let's do it
okay and then we teach you to save we
teach you to give we teach you to spend
wisely after we taught you to work hang
on i'm going to send you a copy of the
financial piece junior kit which will
show you how to teach your five-year-old
exactly how we taught our kids growing
up and a copy of rachel's book that i
did with her called smart money smart
kids on how to teach your kids how to
handle money it covers every bit of this
that's a really good question
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
family
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in the lobby of ramsey solutions and on
the debt-free stage bobby and cindy are
with us hey guys how are you we're great
how are you great great to be here
honored to have you where do you guys
live
we live in charlotte north carolina cool
welcome to nashville thank you how much
debt have you paid off uh we paid off 68
000. cool how long did this take
uh two years good for you and your range
of income during that time
uh we were about 85 000 and we ended at
about 158 whoa nice jump what do you all
do for a living
uh bobby's a controversial contractor
home improvement and things like that
and then i'm was a finance manager with
a law uh with a law firm and then
actually
just when we were about finished with
our our debt i went out on my own and
started my own bookkeeping business and
that's where the increase came a little
bit of both actually um he
received a number
it took off tremendously as soon as uh
covert hit
my construction business went crazy yeah
everybody was home so they wanted work
to be done well they happened to notice
that that stuff was broken they didn't
see it before because they weren't ever
there yeah when you visit that bathroom
10 times a day you get to see a
difference and if you're only there
twice
what kind of debt was the 68 000 you
know it's all the normal stuff but
primarily credit cards car loans some
medical bills camper loan
uh you name it it was just normal it was
what we had grown up with it was what we
had always lived with both of our lives
we had never really had any
kind of financial guidance or
um yeah nothing when i grew up my my
parents were pretty poor
um so
it was always couponing for me
i even do it my business
he's my master couponer i love it i love
it good good so how long y'all been
married
uh seven and a half years so what
happened two years ago the pandemic and
what i mean is that kind of what woke
you up or what was the wake-up call not
really i think you know our journey
started kind of a couple years before
that we actually had around 90 000 in
debt
and you know but over five years we
realized like we had barely moved that
needle you know we maybe moved at 20
000. the more we were making seemed like
the more we were spending
yeah kind of
kept living up to the lifestyle and and
just you know you you think it's normal
but you're really just playing a show
game of you know you pay off one thing
and you think oh i've got an extra 300
on my budget we'll go get a camper you
know so you know you just you just you
know stupid builds upon stupid yeah over
and over and we
when we first moved here from
massachusetts where we're from
uh we came here and we were here for
about a year but as we came to lord
and it changed everything yeah a lot of
things changed and and it was up to
about three years ago that
i found out that this is not my money
this is the lord's money yeah and what
are we going to do with this so it that
started the ball going
really being a good steward of
recognizing that you know the money
wasn't ours it was a gift and a blessing
from the lord so and that's hardly that
flipped the switch to cause you to get
intense it did and then you got involved
in this and she was talking about you
and i'm like this is dave ramsey
this is another scam what are you doing
now
[Music]
you know and i think the thing for both
of us is you know um you know bobby
didn't really i think get fully engaged
but he trusted me to do it and i think
you know we hear so much about everybody
having their budget meetings and doing
all of this stuff together and our
journey was a little bit different we
weren't really so much on the budget
component of it i certainly use the um
the ever dollar app
which by the way you need to rebrand
that as the every penny app because
i'm telling you i was so intense on
using that app and you know if the
electric bill was you know 30 cents over
i was adjusting it in the every dollar
app and then finding that 30 cents
someplace else to either spend it or or
to um save some place out so and i just
went along with her you know i i
i actually just said there you go okay
yeah take over because stayed out of the
way i i did i really did
you know i didn't i did coupons
and that was for our vacation money too
so yeah yeah yeah he loves to anything
he saves on a coupon he takes that money
that's his own envelope system and he
kind of puts it aside and says okay now
how much money do we have in the you
know in the uh the vacation fund here so
how does it feel now that you're free
incredible it's just really
life-changing i gotta pinch myself every
morning i get up i am telling you
i i'm 66 67 whatever it is but
i wish i was their age
when this happened yeah you know what my
life would be right now but you know i
can't cry over that no but
here i am at this age so
if i can do it anybody can do it oh yeah
it's incredible well and i think the
other thing that happens when you no
longer have that debt not only does it
you know it changes you know like like
romans tells us you know we are not to
conform to this world and i think that
the way the world views money
is that's what we were doing we were
conforming to the world view of it's
okay to have debt it's okay to not have
a future
and to suddenly have a future and to be
able to have that freedom um just by
being different um it's it's it's bold
to be
a christian in this day and age but it's
also bold to be debt-free and so for us
i think it was a combination it walks
hand in hand with how we are being good
stewards but also what we're doing um
for our future we've come we've become
the people that we should have been
that we want a long time but we wanted
to be yes but i think the other thing
too is you know how we're using um our
resources now you know bobby moved his
sister um from
florida to portland oregon so talk about
going from one end of the country to the
other
but that took two weeks and you know a
year ago or two years ago we would have
never been able to have even considered
the generosity of time and effort that
it took to do that because that would
have meant two weeks of income out of
that we're able to do things like that
we help our church we help our family
i said i think you had a picture of my
granddaughter you know when he was in
portland i went up and took care of my
granddaughter for the weekend and you
know just to be able to have those type
of experiences
um and it's never been able to do that
before bobby hi special this question's
burning a hole in my heart
how can you run a construction business
without a 120 000 truck loan
is that possible she's got the truck
i was given a 98 chevy suburban by one
of our our church members church members
free and it's still still get the job
done i have that to this day that's all
i use you're a magician my brother well
done
so it's funny because your last um
uh debt-free couple you know they said
well they're pretty private and and we
are too
and i think there are people who have
helped us without realizing they were
helping us like the gift of that
suburban you know he said i'm not going
to get anything for it as a dealer do
you want this for a work truck
and and talk about a god thing literally
his old van had just died
so you know i'm you know the god will
god will just lay out the path for you
if you will just listen to him and you
will follow him
um and you guys are blessed us in so
many ways you're you're heroes i'm so
proud of you thank you no problem
absolutely well done and we appreciate
you if it wasn't for you we i don't
think we'd be here i didn't do it no i
know but
but you know god
yes god put you in our path for a reason
and and i think that it's important for
people to realize that you know i'm 56
he's 66 you can do this you know and and
so you know our next journey is to get
that house paid off and we've laid out
the plan that that's a five-year plan
there you go so
you know it just it builds hope upon
hope upon hope and that's what we are
praying that this will do for other
people all right well it's bobby and
cindy from charlotte north carolina we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you and a copy of total money
makeover for you because we want you to
be millionaires and give that total
money makeover book to somebody and get
them started they paid off 68 000
in two years but i think a whole lot
more than that happened making 85 to 158
i love it you guys are amazing count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one we're dead free
yes
[Applause]
wow
powerful
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five
john uh
we use a lot of uh
joke lines and um
one-liners for people's memories uh
around here for different things live
like no one else so later you can live
like no one else for better than i
deserve uh one of the things is we just
yell all the time don't be normal normal
sucks and she brought that up in that
last step free scream
um
the
do not be conformed to this world
but be transformed
by the renewing of your mind
romans 12 2 and so
what happens is if you don't want to be
normal
you have to renew your mind
and what's interesting is there's so
much data out now
that uh
confirms that biblical truth that your
mind can literally be
literally
with the neural pathways can be renewed
and i love it that it's renewing that
it's a it's a
it's not for me it's not a one-stop it
didn't happen once like i'm constantly
renewing that thing right i'm constantly
learning and being around wise people
and getting new insights and
um i love that okay but your brain
literally changes neuroplasticity right
i love it neuroplastic
that thoughts have a physical shape to
them yeah they've
got a weight yeah there's an actual
thing that they can measure that as a
thought and a negative thought
has a place a physical place that it
lives a positive thought has a physical
place and a chemical reaction that works
through yeah as a result and so being
normal
and considering that normal in our
culture today is
overweight
broke
exhausted full of anxiety
horrible
relationships kids are out of control
marriage is on the rocks
uh i hate my job
normal is it sucks it's that line just
is what it is it's and i just reject
that wholesale it's not it it is what it
is but it shouldn't be it shouldn't be
yeah it doesn't have to be and i love
what she said she said i don't want to
be normal yeah i don't want to be like
everybody else i i don't
and it what part of their journey was
not that they mathematically paid off
the debt part of their journey was they
no longer accepted normal as okay they
were they were turned inside out
yeah
and you know
the the new book you've got coming out
own your past change your future your
reform and use story as a way to to
reset the thought patterns in the brain
right with the newer neuroplasticity
and so what we've been doing with
teaching people how to get out of debt
is reject the cultural norm
that is destroying your life by the way
and that's true of how you've been
taught to handle trauma or how you've
been taught to handle your mental health
uh your worry
your anxiety your panic attack uh how
you've been taught to
handle uh boundaries with your crazy
mother-in-law isolation loneliness lack
of friendships toxic work environments
all of it right we're just told this is
just the way this is and
life is short and then you die yep and
it is short and you die
but man there's a lot more autonomy and
a lot more transformation that can
happen in that gap and you can choose
that's right
to not be conformed yeah
not be normal
with the
renewing be transformed
transformed
with the renewing of your mind and
that's true when you're getting out of
debt it's true when you're getting a new
job with ken coleman it's true with own
your past change your future and you
want a different mental health
outlook
and mental health by the way
i i think some of you are caught up to
this but some of you aren't when we're
talking about mental health around here
we're not talking about everyone that
that is cr that
anyone who wants to deal with mental
health is crazy no i want better health
i want better physical health i want
better mental
health right that's exactly what we're
sitting here talking about
neuroplasticity new thoughts renewing
your mind that is the health of your
mental it get it doesn't mean crazy
because but mental health i kind of
people in my generation admit it's like
it's like if you go to a marriage
counselor you must be about a divorce if
you if you say mental health it means uh
oh crazy award gotcha and so once you
say mental health is like whoa that's
over there that's those other people
yeah but no i want to be healthy yeah
mentally in fact i i even go as far to
say that there's really no such thing as
physical health and mental health and
relational health and spiritual it's all
just health now that we know enough that
my thoughts actually
impact my physiology and my lack of
sleep impacts decision making all that
stuff works together man if you don't
have relationships your body's going to
be hollering at you to get connected and
all that stuff works together but yeah i
want to have better control of my
thoughts and i want to stop waking up at
2 am every night after every night i
want to stop having my body take off on
me just because me and my wife get a
disagreement i want to take i want to be
more engaged parent i want all these
things that's mental health and that's
spiritual health that's right take every
thought captive yes i'm not going to
allow i'm going to make a conscious
decision
that uh and you know our debt free
screamer in an earlier
uh segment today
how'd you do that i'm just not worried
about what the guys at work think yeah
he took a thought captive
he took a thought the cat that thought
the thought that i need to impress other
people i took that captive and i tossed
it to the curb
the idea that the world uh revolves
around you right this zip tie it duct
tape its mouth and throw it to the curb
yeah i mean i'm gonna take this thought
captive i'm gonna
capture it
i'm gonna kidnap it and throw it out of
my brain yeah you know and you can get
physically in your mind almost look at
that i'm a zip tie hog tie
i don't cowboy rope i don't know what
you're gonna do how is it you capture
something in your world right
but uh and throw that thing to the curb
man and that's what he did he just said
i
wasn't worried about what they thought
yeah it was me and her and you know
we come back to this choice thing dave
i've been through enough debt-free
screams now did you know the smile is
the same when somebody says we paid off
170 000 house
and we paid off our million dollar house
the smile's the same because it's
they're smiling for freedom right and
there's this this we get caught up in
this choice of
well yeah i'll never have 100 million
great
you can still be a millionaire you can
still be free you can still right you're
we're making these choices
that um we tend to instagram them or
well that influence right man the smile
over here is the same when people are
free they are free and you make that
choice for you and your family in that
season man and then you get after it
it's just something i don't know i
always thought freedom would be when it
was
500 million or 600 million or 100
i watch this this freedom on people and
it's just something else 55 000 bucks
yeah i paid off 60 grand and my whole
family is different now and my whole
life is i became the person i should
have been that's what he said that was a
great line i became the person i wanted
to become man it's a great line
it's just something beautiful man that
we get caught up in the choice
comparison in the champ just choose and
go for it
well i i know that there's a way that
we're going to come up with to redeem
the value in social media
but there's so much harm done yeah
that i'm i'm really comfortable just
being off of it yeah i mean i'm on it
but i got people here that run it i'm
not on it anymore i quit i just quit
yeah i can't stand it
it drives me bananas and um
and i just i have i have to make a
choice
what i'm going to put into my brain yeah
i mean what because whatever i put in my
program if i put crap in my brain my
brain is crap yep yeah and there's
something uh you know i put hate in my
brain i just stay mad all the time well
yeah your body responds to it and ready
to fight right um this past week i was
in new york for a bunch of media
meetings and
it was the week that they had just been
released yeah
and i tell you what man it was
almost
teary-eyed
i just watched these friends and these
co-workers hadn't been together in
months coming together and having these
first time they've seen each other
physically
since 2020 there was laughter from their
guts there was
deep conversations like truly how are
you questions not just passing
man you don't get that on this room you
don't you don't get done you don't get
that on instagram you don't get that
thumbs up by the way those 43 people on
facebook aren't your real friends no
they won't be there at 2am if you have a
problem
they don't even know you're there right
they're not even sure they're who you
are but they click friend there's
something powerful dave about
getting well getting connected and being
free that's why i'm excited to go back
and do these live events again
in person yeah i mean i'm not gonna get
to have a conversation with two thousand
people but i'm gonna get to be with two
thousand people and i'll be with you
that's right and be with you and be with
rachel and george and you know this is
just who we are here at ramsey and so
some of you don't like that and it's
okay you don't have to come
there's room
you know it's gonna sell out anyway but
we'd love to have you but you don't have
to come just come just try it just try
it you'd be amazed what happens this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money thank you for
joining us we'll also answer questions
about your mental health your
relationships your boundaries
your
career your job we talk about all of it
right here alan's going to start off
this hour in cheyenne wyoming hi alan
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hey thank you guys for taking my
call sure what's up
um okay first i retired in uh the end of
2012.
i'm 74 now i make about 100k
a year in pensions
the only debt that we have is our home
which is 52
000
have 120 000 in the bank
i have a uh
62k in a 457
where i used to work and i've been
taking the minimum distribution amount
since 70 since i was 70 and a half
um my question is
do i pay the 20
tax rate which is about 12k
to pay the house off or take it out of
out of the bank account
i'm asking because with about five to
seven interest hikes this year predicted
uh will that clobber the change in value
over the next few years
i lost a quarter of a percent of it the
last quarter of 21.
so do i take it out now while it's still
worth something what is your income
pardon me what's your income
100k about 100k a year okay
well the 20 you're referring to is not
the tax rate
the 20 is the with the 20 percent is the
withholding rate unless you are in a 20
tax bracket and if you make 100k you're
not in a 20 tax bracket
yeah i'm right sorry
so
the 20 is withholding so it'll be your
tax rate that you'll pay on it when you
pull it out early uh no i just use your
bank money
because it's not making anything anyway
it's 55 000 out of 120 000 and you're
debt free write the check today
okay
okay well and that's what i was
wondering i just didn't know about you
know the the the
the interest rate
hikes they're going to do over the next
few years and
really that that may or may not affect
what are you invested in in your 457
in mutual funds it's a
fixed income fund oh
low risk okay well that will be affected
by the interest rate hikes um
and probably positively
uh you're not making much on it anyway
so um
yeah you got it parked very
conservatively there so i but i'm still
i'm still gonna leave it alone i mean
i'm still going to let let it sit there
and grow without giving the government
uh 30 which is what you're going to give
them
there's not a wrong answer but i think
the better answer is the take the money
out of the 120 000 in checking write a
55 000 check and your house is debt-free
with the fixed income
withdrawal there i thought raising
interest rates would help that fund
it will it will but probably not
substantially it's probably not making
anything and it'll make double a very
little gotcha
you know so i mean but trying to beat
that doubling one you get two you're
trying to
is at a loss of 30 yeah that's that's
the problem yeah so yeah i'll just leave
it alone
uh kate is with us in des moines iowa hi
kate welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are you great how can we help
i have a question for dr daloni um i was
wondering how to process the trauma of
having
a previous toxic toxic roommate and so
that i can live with people again
walk me through what happened
well um so when
i first moved out of my parents house
i was moving in with my brother and what
was his current roommate
and um i didn't realize that
when i moved in with them that they were
involved with one another and
it caused like a almost a control issue
because it was almost like two against
one and he allowed
her to
get free reign because he um she was
his partner so it
caused some like tension and i would
like try to clean up around the house
and she would get upset that i was
cleaning up after him because she
thought that he should be able to clean
up after himself and it just made it so
it was
hard to
be anywhere except for my own room
so is the trauma that
you
were disconnected from your brother that
your brother ended up siding with
somebody that wasn't you is that the
trauma or is it that somebody was
overbearing in your home and they were
telling you what to do
and it caught you off guard and it just
became overwhelming
probably a little bit of both like it
was very hard for me that my brother was
fighting with somebody else but also
just
if my family can do that to me
what what makes it so somebody else
wouldn't do that to me if i were to get
a roommate again there you go okay so an
important part of trauma is that our
body's responding in the present to
things that have happened in the past
okay so the idea i can hear it on you
the idea of
being alone isn't
smart it's not good it's not safe
and yet the idea of being with somebody
else if my brother can do this to me can
abandon me for some girlfriend then who
else
um then everybody's capable of this
right and so there is some truth to that
that anybody can hurt you that's all
relationship is a risk what i would tell
you is
unfortunately i've seen it
the other way whereas family is often
more likely to run over other family
members because they think they have the
right to do that or they think oh it's
just my dumb little sister or my dumb
big brother
and often agreed upon people take more
time to come up with boundaries when
it's people they don't know or when it's
new roommates so this is how we do we do
laundry this is who does the dish people
have those conversations with new
roommates
and so for you the word i would give you
is number one you got to grieve it you
got to just own the fact that your
brother
screwed you over right and didn't treat
you like you felt you wanted to be
treated and um number two
you're gonna have to practice and i know
that sounds hard but you're gonna have
to lean into what's a relationship gonna
look like what are boundaries gonna look
like in this new relationship um and i
would not hold
new roommates hostage to the way your
brother treated you it's not normal it's
not right
and coming into a new relationship with
boundaries is gonna really help that so
you know if you're not willing to help
with the dishes help with the rent help
with the bills help with the widow then
um this isn't going to be a good
situation then you should be on to the
next
but it's deeply personal when your
brother hurts you isn't it
great
have you talked to him about it and his
poor choice of girlfriends yeah
have you talked to him about it
yeah it's been it's been a couple years
now and i am in an apartment by myself
now and it's just a little bit affecting
my finances because it's a little bit
more than what i want to be spending and
so i we've
that he's married to her now
yeah she's very touristy oh see that
complicates it all
i think you got to have a hard
conversation with him until this still
hurts with her it still hurts
and hopefully he'll say oh my gosh i'm
so sorry
um
and that'll let you be free of some of
this
dave
have at it try it again yeah i think you
can you can learn from this and say now
i know how to have boundaries that's
right never again never again
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is a best-selling
author and host of the dr john deloney
show
hey guys there's never been a better
time to find a job doing work you love
and that's why i can't wait to tell you
about the exciting roles that we have
open here at ramsey solutions
we are hiring about 300 folks this year
we need developers ux designers writers
to help us build the digital products
that actually change people's lives
and if you want to see what it's like to
work here well you can follow us on
instagram and facebook by searching
ramsay careers
uh all kinds of fun stuff going on here
it's a lot of hard work and a lot of
really really smart people that care
very very deeply
and so if you want to mail it in and
collect a paycheck uh probably not your
place
because we get after it
because what we're doing really really
matters to us and it matters to the
people we work for you guys that listen
so you can apply for your dream job at
ramsey solutions dot com slash careers
ramsey solutions dot com slash
careers
john one of the things that has happened
uh with this surge in real estate is a
surge in real estate values
a lot of you are sitting on a home that
is worth a whole lot more
than it was 20 minutes ago than it was
two years ago than it was three years
ago
there was a big hurricane and i can't
remember the name of it that hit florida
and did massive destruction before
katrina hit new orleans so several years
back in other words
and after that hurricane
state farm made the decision
that they were no longer doing
policies that covered the value of the
house
instead they're going to do policies
homeowners policies that they state the
value
and the state farm is the biggest player
in the homeowners insurance world and so
everyone followed suit
and and sometimes some of the policies
uh you know whereas you buy a house for
300 000 bucks will make up a number and
you buy a homeowner's policy for 300 000
bucks to cover the home you just bought
and it might have an inflation clause on
it that the next year it's a little bit
more next year it's a little bit more
but it would be it would not be unusual
for a whole bunch of you listening right
now
to have a home that you paid 300 for
that you've got 350 000 worth of
coverage with those inflation kickers on
them and the things worth 550 000 and it
burns down and you can't rebuild it you
can't build a driveway with 300 000 yeah
yeah and so
what what i'm telling you is is that you
ha it is now incumbent upon you because
the insurance business changed as of
that hurricane that i can't remember the
name of
the insurance business changed and it's
basically stated value plus or minus
inflation kickers and the inflation
kickers aren't enough wow and so you
have to
revisit
your homeowners insurance once a year
and make sure you have the right amount
of coverage for the value of the house
how will you evaluate your your home on
an annual basis like that i mean you can
jump on just one of those websites and
look at it you're not going to be far
off but you kind of know i got 189 000
worth of coverage and this house is
worth 600 grand our neighbors just sold
their house right yeah so you know
you're like way off yeah and so you can
toss that to your insurance provider and
they they'll they'll do a little
research on it and tell you what to
cover the house for but you need to
update your coverage because the value
of your home is growing
and your policy's not you know what
really freaks me out is the millions of
people who in 2020 and 2021
when the housing prices started to surge
took out a big home equity loan to pay
for their new bathroom they want to get
done during that gap and now
not only is the insurance coverage not
there
but they're going to be on the hook for
that that loan they're going to be
staring at a burn down lot holding a
check that can't replace the driveway
plus you owe me us this equity loan
exactly you could what a mess if you'd
refinance the first mortgage they would
have required you to update the
insurance but many times a home equity
loan doesn't wow what a run this you're
exactly right so you could you could
literally be upside down in the house
like like on an old days old days in a
car yeah that kind of thing so what i'm
telling you is get online a day at
ramseysolutions.com and click the elp
for insurance
and get a free quote on your car
insurance and your homeowner's insurance
and keep your homeowners insurance
updated
for the right amount of coverage because
if your house burns down and you have 50
of it covered you're going to build a
very small house in that lot
i mean you're going to be screwed up and
if you've got a mortgage you know your
mortgage is probably less than that
you're going to end up with nothing
that's zero you'll pay off the mortgage
and have a burned up lot yeah that's all
you're gonna have and so that's you're
gonna be in a mess
so make sure you keep your coverage up
to date and always price shop it with
one of these uh insurance brokers now
the difference in a broker
and somebody like state farm uh one of
these name brands uh you know if they've
got a uh
uh uh a celebrity endorser they're
probably a captive
company meaning state farm agents can
only sell state farm or a lizard
that's right
that lizard thing that's the other one
yeah um and and so you can you know uh
nationwide can only sell nationwide and
so you know that they they're captive
agents that's what we call them in the
insurance business so instead you want
to get a broker that will shop a bunch
of different companies and find you the
best price in your situation
and so many times when someone goes to
ramseysolutions.com clicks on the elp
and gets with an insurance broker and
shops they not only get the right amount
of coverage because their house has gone
up in value but they also get a cheaper
rate
and uh so if you're buying the same
amount of insurance a lot of people save
seven eight hundred bucks a year by
changing their car and their home owners
or auto and homeowners over and um
because they're just people are we're
fairly lazy
about our insurance shopping sure
uh we get it in place it's it's uh rip
it and forget it right i mean you just
put it on there and you pay the bill you
pay the pill you pay the bill unless
something comes up and shakes you up but
i'm telling you right now
i don't know what the percentage is but
i would guess
um
north of 50 of you listening to me right
now that own a home do not have the
proper amount of coverage on your home
because your home's gone up in value and
you didn't update your coverage
and the insurance companies do not
update it they are not they took that
responsibility
away from themselves and gave it to you
and having sat in this middle of a
street with somebody watching their
house burned down on a couple of
different occasions
that sounds like a nightmare on top of a
nightmare oh it is it's one of the most
horrible things to go through
emotionally and then on top of that to
not have the money to rebuild is just a
horrible thing so make sure you're
updating your insurance ramsey
solutions.com click on elp michelle's
with us in cleveland ohio hi michelle
how are you
hi dave i'm good thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um
twofold i have um
i got an esop distribution from a
company that i worked for
and it's about 1.4 million
sitting in
a schwab account it's in an ira
and i'm
with everything that's going on i'm
afraid about having all my eggs in one
basket
and my husband and i are both retired
i'm 61 he's 67
but we still have a mortgage and a home
equity line of credit
um
we don't have any credit cards we're
debt-free in the credit cards and up
until last week we had two paid off cars
but
an engine received in one of our cars so
we had to go buy a car this week um
my question is whether to given what's
going on in the world and you know the
great reset i was just watching i have
glenn beck's book and i was just
watching your program that aired today
um
i'm just a little afraid
obviously of having all my eggs in one
basket
and given what's going on in the world
if we should just take i think there's
about 160 000 that we could take out in
cash and just pay everything off you
should do that anyway but not because of
the fear of what's going on in the world
it's a smart financial move
you should
you've got a million dollars you should
not be carrying around a home mortgage
with a couple hundred grand you ought to
be paying it off
okay well that was that was my thought
process too but not because not because
of the great reset just because it's
smart to pay off your mortgage
okay okay then and same thing never
borrow money on a car again you're a
millionaire come on girl
i know i was planning on paying it off
next year oh how about just never
borrowing on a car again
you're not a broke person you're a
millionaire
now with the rest of the money with the
rest of money what i would do is sit
down with a smartvestor pro click ramsey
solutions and click smart buster pro and
find somebody in the investment business
that can help you do a rollover and get
that diversified across several types of
mutual funds and give you a little more
safety
yeah i'm with you i would not have it
all in one account but i'm not sure what
you've got with schwab there necessarily
you may not really be in one account but
i'd be in several different mutual funds
with that much money and i'd be
debt-free you put borrow money on cars
you're a millionaire
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host
thank you for joining us in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
larry and camisha are with us hey guys
how are you hey dave how are you how's
it going welcome where do you guys live
we currently live in fayetteville north
carolina and we just moved there from
tallahassee florida
all right fun fun well welcome to
nashville all the way here to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off
five
60
and sixty three dollars love it now you
were counting right how long did this
take 20 months dave good for you and
your range of income during that time
when we first started this journey it
was 84 000 and when we ended it was 116
000. wow nice jump good job what do
y'all do for a living i'm a program
director working with people with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities and i'm a business analyst
at a university okay very good good for
you guys what kind of debt was the 61
000
credit cards student loans
car payment
a car loan
we had a
college loan well it wasn't a loan it
was parking tickets oh
yeah so you guys were normal oh yeah how
long have you been married be four years
in june all right so what happened two
years ago halfway into this marriage and
you went uh-uh something got to change
what happened what was what was the the
deal breaker that got you on this ramsey
stuff the deal breaker i think on our
honeymoon we had the biggest argument
ever
oh
no we hadn't talked about money much
and so it just came out and we just had
a huge money argument and
it was just like man it was a wake-up
call like man
who was wrong i wasn't
clearly
clearly
clearly you are wise
he's wiser than fighting on his
honeymoon
he's learned yeah all right yeah i had
to you know just make some decisions
what happened what happened 20 months
ago we got you on this plan so i've been
talking with my pastor for a while in
tallahassee and he kind of introduced me
to to dave ramsey and the plan and i
just woke me up and i'm like man we can
we can do this and so just trying to get
her on board like let's do this this is
going to really help us and really help
uh change our lives and change but she
was already wanting to do it back at the
honeymoon yeah no no no it was the wrong
oh
i was the free spirit i wanted to spin
spin spin okay oh no did she call you
chief on your honeymoon yeah it's my
fault
[Laughter]
all right so kamisha how how did he get
you
to consider this whole new way of
handling and looking at money well he
brought it to my attention and i still
was not impressed
and then one of my co-workers she
actually went through your plan and her
and her husband became debt-free and she
shared the story with me and i said okay
lynn just told me about this you know
larry just told me about this let's give
it a try
eight months into it i still was not
convinced i still wasn't convicted yeah
we took fpu in in february of 2020 right
before the pandemic here you are a
hardship yeah
absolutely a hard sale absolutely
eight months of the 20 but what happened
then
how did you become convinced we paid off
our credit cards she started seeing
results ah started seeing the results
and it was worth it you started saying
it was worth it absolutely and believing
you were actually going to make it yes
clearly we were so busy because we're
both in school so we're both in school
getting our masters and we have a
three-year-old and just trying to
balance everything we're both graduating
this semester
uh so what are your masters in i'm
getting my master's in uh master's in
public administration and autism
spectrum disorders oh yeah beautiful wow
and hey there's nothing like a pandemic
to pucker up a university business
analyst right there you go there you go
there you go wide open wow i've got some
buddies that were so wet still sweating
right
okay we should probably get out of debt
absolutely so it was definitely a
wake-up call and you know we were on on
the track ahead of time and then you
know with that pandemic hit it was like
our last two classes of fpu we we did
remote and so it's like man this we have
to really pay off this debt wow it goes
full steam ahead
so i'm guessing that neither of you had
a picture growing up of
what debt-free living looked like
absolutely not no not not too much i
know my parents uh you know we were in
good position and really prepared us but
really not that you know for this
debt-free journey was something new uh
for us but i knew it was you know it was
our purpose what do you think
man you're a three-year-old what tell me
about what you're thinking about having
a three-year-old that will never
understand that level of stress will
never understand not being completely
and totally free we look at her with so
much gratitude and we were just talking
about her today and we said she's so
blessed she doesn't know the things that
she won't get to experience you know
that we were able to protect her from
just by going through this journey wow
absolutely change the family tree so
will you ever go back in that oh no no
no no
no credit cards we actually um when we
took the fpu class he was the only one
to cut up his credit card like first day
and we cut the credit card and we have
not used credit cards since did you hit
him on the way home in the car no no i
was impressed
yeah and we just finished leading fpu um
as well we just finished our week nine
was on sunday wow thank you leading our
class thank you so much at the new place
in fayetteville yeah wow
very cool well thank you for doing that
well you guys are star pupils no
question about it i'm proud of you thank
you very very well done absolutely now
that you're a hundred percent free
and you're on the same page
how's it feel
it's gratitude it just feels i'm just
i'm grateful
i'm so grateful uh just to to be able to
lead my family
um into greater pasture and to know that
i'm really uh walking this thing that
you know the call of life that god
really designed us to walk it the right
way and to not be a borrower anymore uh
never again so uh we're on this journey
together i love it making it happen yeah
preach it i like it all right
what's one thing uh you can give us that
a husband can tell his wife when she's
like i'm eight months in i'm not doing
this
give me give give america one line
be patient
be patient and to the wives i would say
you know trust your spouse
i was so afraid i had fomo fear of
missing out i didn't want to let go of
things and i had to just let go and just
trust him because he was trying to lead
us in the right direction but i was
worrying about my status and you know
wanting to get my nails done and wanted
to go out to eat but it was bigger than
that and so he had the vision from the
beginning and i just had to trust him
and trust the process and now you can
get your nails done and go out to eat
whenever you want
anytime you want you got no dad i love
it
absolutely live like no one else later
you can live and give like no way no one
else all right now when you're teaching
the class what are you telling the key
to getting out of debt is
for me it was just really losing your
reputation
i think i really had to lose my
reputation of you know having this
status of having these things and it's
not about that anymore and i had to
really figure out a new reputation my
reputation was to you know
lead my family in the right direction um
also i just had to stop listening to
know how to start listening to broke
people yeah she doesn't like me to say
that but i really had to stop listening
to broke people like if i didn't want to
trade places with you i'm not listening
to your advice
so really you know just studying god's
word and listening to you know your
podcast every day really kept you know
keep us motivated and staying on track
in the right direction you guys are
amazing you're an absolute power couple
we're so proud of you thank you
well done we got a copy of the baby
steps millionaires book for you that's
definitely the next chapter in your
story you are on your way very well done
and a copy of total money makeover you
can give that away to somebody and stir
up a holy ruckus oh yes i like it i like
it all right it's larry and camisha they
paid off 61 000 in 20 months quite an
adventure making 84-116
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three
[Music]
i don't care who you are that's fun
oh man stop taking advice from broke
thief if i don't want to trade places
with you i'm not interested in what you
have to say
how about my that will preach about my
parenting about my marriage about my
money i don't want what you have no
thank you i will pass on that i like it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day first
corinthians 10 13 no temptation has
overtaken you except what is common to
mankind and god is faithful he will not
let you be tempted beyond what you can
bear
but when you are tempted he will also
provide a way out so that you can endure
it
abraham lincoln said discipline is
choosing between what you want now and
what you want most ouch
that's good
travis is with us in charlotte north
carolina hi travis welcome to the ramsay
show
yes sir how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
uh first off i need to say thank you i
feel like you and your team and your
plan uh have definitely saved my
marriage
um so i'm active military and we're
getting ready to sell our house which
the profit from selling our house we
will pay off all our debt
and then have roughly about fifty
thousand dollars left wow very cool um
so with that being said we're you know
we're moving because of the military so
we're moving from charlotte area to west
virginia um so we'll be taking a pay cut
um and we'll be debt free so with that
extra 50 000 is that something i've
talked to a couple of financial advisors
is that something that we put towards
the house we'll be using a va loan to
purchase a house
i've talked with others that say you
know to put it in a roth ira
um and i've talked to a couple that say
it's not a bad idea to always invest in
you know gold and silver um so i'm just
kind of curious what to do with that
amount of money
because we've been in debt uh just
forever so we're we're kind of going
into
no man's land yeah well thanks for your
service
so um how long will you be stationed in
west virginia
um hopefully it's my last move um but
probably around five years
okay
all right
um well be careful when you buy a home
there
that you um
that you buy in an area that is hot
enough that you can resell it because
i'm assuming after five years you're not
going to stay in west virginia am i
right
that's correct okay so i mean you need
to be able to get rid of this house when
you leave
and so if you buy in an area that is um
that is slow moving in real estate it's
not going to go up enough in value and
you're going to have trouble getting rid
of it so be careful of that do some
studying with the real estate agent when
you are
picking the area okay
okay so that's thing one thing two
uh uh you're you're not disabled because
you're still active duty right
uh correct the i am yes okay so the va
loan is not your best deal
it's it's more expensive than a fannie
mae loan it's a it is a a benefit to
veterans into active duty and it should
be
since it is supposed to be a way to
honor you guys and gals for serving it
should be cheaper but it's actually more
expensive than an fha or more expensive
than a fannie mae even yet and so i
would do a conventional loan and if you
want to you know pick out a realtor that
we suggest just click on real estate elp
under ramsey trusted ramsey
solutions.com you can find the real
estate agent they'll help you line all
that out and they'll show you the
numbers i'm talking about
but the the va loan
has been sold to you as part of your
package and it's something that was
supposed to be good for you
uh but they're so stupid in how they run
it as you can imagine that it's more
expensive so i wouldn't go that route so
that that's thing one uh then the last
piece is i'm going to put all the money
towards the house other than debt free
and have an emergency fund because i'm
going to put as much down as i can
because we have the goal of getting the
home paid off even if you're going to
move
later if you have a huge equity because
you paid down the home aggressively and
use this down payment you're going to
get all that money out of the house when
you sell it
so put as much down as you can
and whoever the advisor was that told
you to buy silver or gold never go near
them again yeah don't
don't drink beer with them don't mow
their yard just walk away man
yeah here's why i just pulled this
number as a matter of fact i hadn't
looked at it in a while but i pulled it
because of something else i was doing
today
i was on my friend glenn beck's show and
he's a big gold bug and
um the last 10 years
gold has an average annual rate of
return of 3.7
and the stock market has an average of
12.4
that's why i'm telling you to run from
people suggesting gold
okay
and so i i do not invest in precious
metals of any kind ever
i invest in real estate that i pay cash
for and i invest in good growth stock
mutual funds
that a good smart investor pro at ramsey
solutions can hook you up with we're not
in the real estate business and we're
not in the investment business but we'll
hook you up with people that will help
you
do the thing you're trying to do
purchase a piece of real estate make the
investments the way that we teach
consistent with the way we teach alan is
with us in lexington hi alan your
question
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
um
yeah
my son
is staying with us right now and he has
been going through severe depression as
a result
he uh
he quit his job uh he's from alabama but
he quit his job now he's working with
boeing and um
he had credit card debt couldn't keep up
with his credit card payments and so
they turned over to collection agency
which then went to a lawyer and so we're
tr we came up because i've listened to
you a lot so we came up with an amount
we would pay them
and he's fifteen thousand dollars in
debt we came up with an amount we would
pay them they would not even talk to us
they said they had to talk to a lawyer
through us
and so i'm just wondering where to go
from here
well that's absolute horse crap yeah
that's not true that's just not true
[Laughter]
now they're not allowed to talk to you
about his
they
account
to talk to him about his account unless
they have a legal document allowing them
to uh discuss with you but they don't
really want that document because they
don't want to talk to they want to bully
him and they've already figured out they
can't bully you yeah they may be talking
about power of attorney for you to speak
on his behalf of his account
um right yeah because they don't they
cannot disclose stuff about his account
because he's an adult to another adult
without his permission it's violation of
federal privacy act
right but they don't but they don't have
to go through a lawyer to have this
discussion now power of attorney
if you misunderstood or they
misunderstood that you yeah you'd have
to get a power of attorney
a special power attorney allowing you to
negotiate this on his behalf um and you
know we used to do some of that
negotiating stuff on behalf of customers
that we were coaching them and so we
would have people sign this power of
attorney and we would send it to the
people but the clerk the creditors they
they hate it because they then they
found somebody they can't bully
um and their goal is to bully him so
what what state of mind is he in right
now
he's gotten a lot better he's got he's
um he's working with a therapist and uh
could he moxie up five minutes of badass
to get on the phone and bust him
i think he could right now yes and see
the other reason they want to talk to us
is there's several of us on there to
talk to them and they they said we
cannot take conference calls so well
then they said and we can't talk to you
know talk to him unless it's through a
lawyer so that's nonsense that's just
not true so here's what i would do i
would have him
um
practice this with his counselor and
this can be a really big breakthrough
moment for him practice the conversation
and have him tell his counselor i want
to practice this because i'm going to be
calling this credit card company that is
i got behind and now they're raking me
over the coals heavy conflict my pulse
rate's going to go up that's right and
then that counselor is going to push on
him in a safe environment there so he
can practice this and then he can sit
with you guys and man this could be a
big win for him on multiple levels
well you're you're right and even now
his counselor has actually pushed him
into actually calling this lawyer i mean
for a long time he just ignored he i
mean it was so bad at one time he just
curled up in bed and stayed there okay
and he has come a long way
if you're able to i want you to high
five
just that one statement you gave me
tells me that that counselor is worth
their weight in gold and if you ever
have a chance high five that counselor
there's so many folks that just want to
sit and chat
and sit and talk and this counselor is
pushing him to get out there and
take some action that's such a beautiful
thing i'm so glad that you you found a
therapist that is doing that for you
high correlation between this type of
action and recovery on depression love
it love it love it love it now very good
keep fighting keep fighting but the
answer is no that no one has to have a
lawyer to deal with a stupid credit card
company they're just a stupid credit
card company believe me they're dumber
than a rock
that puts us hour the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600-plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you